NBA champion Finals MVP Andre Iguodala
nice coming to Wired thanks thanks for
Cooper psyched to have you here we're
huge fans sounds like a good
introduction so where do the Warriors
rank in terms of technology in the
league I would say overall with their
most tech-savvy team guys using devices
being checked for it our guys are pretty
on it tell me a little bit about sort of
when you go to practice every day how
algin how does the science and tax or a
loop into what you guys are doing yes
well our team does a really good job of
how can we maximize our players
potential well they use all three
components combined so these are sports
of you you via mega wave and a catapult
and they say andre's kind of sluggish
you may need a day off from practice for
short and if I'm still a little sluggish
though saying we may need to sit you for
a game or two just to get you back on
track you know we had a lot of depth a
lot of guys who can play so throughout
the season we were smart with minutes
and that was huge for us you know you
saw we won a lot of games by 15 plus
points the stats show the longer a guy
plays the more prone to get injured so
we know when our minutes are down with
fresher you know we can play harder for
shorter bursts I mean we have so many
guys we can just keep people running
them in and out in and it showed our
strength in numbers were in our favor
late in season how does technology
playing a role in your life off the
court some looking for next platforms
that are really innovative can help you
know engage in the community making our
lives easier one company uh press twice
it's a ecommerce marketplace for
secondhand clothing piece clothing has
their journey I just really enjoy the
process and see how it works and I've
been able to come in as a min style
director
what's in your gadget bag when you pack
for a trip waiting 20 what do you have
that with you so my gadget bag usually
have my iPad and I have my macbook in my
cell phones and our cell phones are
important because we have our group sex
as a team and we're all playing
pineapples right now that's the game so
we won the championships or work where
we were so into pineapples I mean we
come in at halftime and play flied out
all right I'm a match against Ramon I
gotta put my cars together throughout
beat them under you Adela
congratulations thanks for coming in
were be pulling for those back fact I
don't text uses thank you